hey guys so I wanted your feedback on a
project I'm working on an idea that that
I came across in the morning I've been
putting out these motivational videos
right there's an inspiring message a
famous entrepreneur I did it for my own
selfish reasons because I felt like I
wanted something that would motivate me
in the morning give me ideas to think
bigger and do something better and so
far the response has been amazing i love
you guys the feedback has been awesome
the comments have been awesome and
here's what happened I met up with a
buddy of mine in front of the channel
Jason fonseka and he's like you know I
love the series but I don't get to
always watch them because YouTube isn't
part of my routine i'm not on youtube
every day in the morning and so I see
them when I see them but I don't watch
it every day and he said you know if you
emailed me the videos I would watch them
if you sent me an email every morning I
checked my email every day and so if you
sent that to me I'd watch them and so my
question for you is do you guys want me
to create an email list just for the
famous videos the inspirational videos
in the morning with the famous
entrepreneur messages would that be
helpful for you so instead of having to
go to you to every morning to watch it
you get it in your email and I'm a
little split you know it's extra work
for me I got to do that extra work if
it's me or someone on my team it's extra
work that we got to put in and I'm happy
to do it if you guys agree if you think
I'd love an email with the message
instead of just watching the videos on
YouTube then we'll do it because I wanna
if that's the difference between you you
know being successful that day because
something hit you something sparked you
and now you're off creating an amazing
business for that day nothing would make
me happier so if that would help you let
me know if you think not I don't want an
email I'm good with just going to
YouTube every morning then that's cool
too i really value your feedback is
gonna have a change in how i promote the
videos so let me know you think people
comment below yay or nay on the
newsletter list idea and that's it
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon